What did we blame for Kamala's loss? Was it Kamala? >> We
don't rewrite
Oh my god. Hutch is destroyed. This is when you catch your like
4-year-old brother with his hand in the cookie jar. >> What
do you That's cool. >> Are you joking?
>> Honestly, Hutch's gaslighting is so counterproductive
on every level.
Let's go over to I think now we're ready to go over to live and
learn, okay? I know the Hassan stuff I've been told the Hassan
stuff was bad already, okay? That is just like basically totally
disconnected from reality. And now, thank god, I think we get
Soy Pill summoning the might
of Kilo in his DMs, okay? I think we finally see the Soy Pill
payoff from all of the caballing Kilo has been doing. >> Do
you ever have a guy who DMs you a ton stuff related to this called
um It'll be like Kilo or Kilo or something like that. >> Kilo
specifically messaged me before our last talk about the Hassan
thing cuz he had some points he wanted to give me. >> Gotcha.
There are There is at least one if not multiple communities that
act in the most insane ways. The These people it's just known
that we're like fighting a lot. So like Queen Man and Jessica
I can't say directly, but what they'll do is they will have They
talk so much to all these other people who will then go out as
like emissaries or ambassadors who will relay these talking points
to people. So what happens is is they get to perfectly speak
their talking points from people like you or somebody who just
doesn't who is just not aware of >> Just so people understand
I know this sounds insane. I sound so schiz when I talk about
this, but >> No, no, no. You're 100% right. >> They
have a whole server where they're talking about it. They workshop
these points. They They forge them. They argue about it on servers.
And then they'll get one person because it just because they
can't pass it off directly cuz it's really obvious. So they'll
get a third party who doesn't make it as obvious that he's associated
with them cuz I don't know if you do Kilo or not who will be
passing all these talking points off to you so that you can carry
these into a conversation with me and then they can all watch
their talking points come through a third and fourth party that
are being debated against me in a way that makes them seem so
much more legitimate. Yeah. >> I think we get Soy Pill
summoning the might of Kilo in his DMs, okay? I think we finally
see the Soy Pill payoff from all of the caballing Kilo has been
doing. That's Whatever Kilo told him, okay? I think we finally
see the payoff here, not to spoil. >> But who do you think
wins in the end? >> I don't think Stevens wins.
>> So, but if she drops, she's more moderate Dem, so her
supporters maybe get behind
McMorrow, so does that put her over the top? >> I don't
know, man. I I feel like we're in a moment right now where people
want to see fighters and people who are opposed to this war.
I think conventional wisdom says that. You keep fighting, you
keep building up the um you keep building everything up, right?
You keep going the same way because you are building momentum
up. You keep going. You fight your best fight. You leave it all
on the field as they say, okay? You don't leave any trick plays,
you don't leave any plans, you don't leave anything left in the
gas tank, okay? You leave it all on the field, you do everything
you can to get this El Say guy elected because it continues momentum
for your movement. Your movement is having a moment. >> And
I haven't done a deep dive in the in these uh into the candidates,
but I think whoever's going to sell that message and be like
a more uh personable candidate, I my guess is they'll have the
edge. And I I don't think this doing this kind of cancellation
strat will see big dividends in the Democratic primary. Now,
maybe ultimately the effect of it will be to be a more competitive
race in the general, but I think that we're going to win Michigan.
I'm not I'm not terribly concerned about
>> Nobody's trying to cancel Hasan [__]
>> I mean, I don't think that's true. The strategy to cancel
him >> The Republicans are definitely trying to like [laughter]
>> Yes, they are trying to >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. What did Hutch just say? Nobody's trying to cancel
Hasan [__] though.
>> There is no way. There's no way Hutch just said nobody's
is to cancel Hasan
Brother, you've been on your soapbox. This guy wants to nuke
Israel. He's a massive anti-Semite.
He should not be involved at all in Democrat politics. You are
trying to cancel him. Not only that, uh how about your adjacency
to
Destiny and Dan and their whole Hasan Piker's an anti-Semite.
The whole campaign they did. WHAT ABOUT THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN?
BROTHER. BROTHER.
BROTHER, WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT,
Nobody's trying to cancel him. Tons of people are trying to cancel
him. Tons of people you're friends with that you hang out with.
Whose streams you go on. The Are you saying nobody's trying to
cancel him? Holy, that's insane cope. What?
>> I mean, I don't think that's true. The the strategy
to cancel him, the Republicans are definitely trying to [laughter]
like Yes, they are trying to Yes, there are definitely people
trying to cancel Hasan and to cancel that I think that we're
going to win Michigan anyway. So, I'm not I'm not terribly concerned
about that. >> Nobody's trying to cancel Hasan [__]
>> I mean, I don't think that's true. The the strategy
to cancel him, the Republicans are definitely trying to >> That's
just like on eight different levels a totally insane thing to
say. >> Uh like [laughter] Yes, they are trying to Yes,
there are definitely people trying to cancel Hasan and to cancel
I'll say >> I mean, like when I think of cancel, I think
like you want you're trying to get them like pushed off of their
platforms. Like take it literally take away their
>> I uh dude, there's just no way. There's just no way.
There's just no way. Hold on. I need to try to go Hold on. What
was on this hasanpiker.com? I actually need to check it now.
Cuz it's it's like the same thing, isn't it?
Yeah, this is like this is like a Dan Saltman website. This hasanpiker.com.
I'm almost positive that Dan came on my stream and I don't know
for sure.
I'm almost positive that Dan came on my stream and talked about
buying this Am I doing misinfo? I maybe I'm doing
So, it's just like a big Hasan is bad Wiki, right?
And it is used All of this was done under the auspices of getting
Hasan banned from Twitch.
It was.
You know, it's been happening for a while, right? I mean, that's
like what what's his name? Dan
Saltman's like whole thing has been trying to like lobby for
it. >> you know, like what >> I'm saying like I'm
saying like the Democrats that have come out and opine on this
what they what I've what I've The only thing I've heard from
Democrats has been
>> Nobody's trying to cancel Hasan.
Nobody's trying to cancel Hasan. Multiple examples of trying
to cancel Hasan? Well, other than the obvious examples of people
trying to cancel
um groups trying to cancel Hasan, have the Democrats tried to
cancel
That was not what you said. That was not what you said at all,
Hutch.
>> That they don't think it's wise or smart to campaign
with someone like Hasan. That's not the same thing as saying
like, you know, cancel.
>> That's also not what their try to their think tanks
have been saying. That's not what several Dems have pushed, right?
Third Way, I do not believe Third Way has any alignment whatsoever
with Republicans. Third Way is a liberal
think tank. They are a Democrat aligned think tank.
Obviously so.
Third Way said, do not associate. Do not Do not talk to him.
Do not go on his Do not support him in any way. Do not be cut
dead with this guy. Don't go on his When he when he When you
hear his name, click toey. I spit on Hasan [__] Click
toey. That's what your reaction should be. That was what the
Third Way article said, okay?
Actually garbage. And by the way, let's not forget
I'm I'm going to have to point it out. Democrat aligned media
ran with that Third Way article and everything in it without
checking anything, without getting any context. They just ran
the narrative one to one. Not No journalism was done. They just
ran that narrative, okay? CNN ran that narrative. I saw Political
running that narrative. A ton of different places ran that narrative
one-to-one with no fact-checking, no
Holy sh- Nobody tried to cancel Hasan [__] Get the
out of here, man.
auto I don't know >> Okay, it's all the same thing. The
kind guilt by association arguments I think are not going to
be landing that much in the primary. I don't think Democrats
are that concerned or tuned into them. >> It's maybe not
just the politicians, but yeah, Fox Fox News and the right has
now picked up the whole like this guy is shouldn't be allowed
to be platformed saying these evil anti-American things. >> want
to They don't want to cancel Hasan. They want more Hasan cuz
like
the fact that Fox News is covering Hasan so much. I've seen so
many people have >> This guy has literally never
had an original thought in his entire life. I It's so obvious
where he gets all of his thoughts from. It's just very sad. I
hate watching it. I hate watching it. So much I hate watching
it so much. >> takes that are like, "Oh, they must be doing
that because they're afraid of Hasan." It's like, "No, they're
doing that because Hasan is toxic >> Easy to attack. >> and
they're they're, you know, using him as a vector to attack the
Democratic Party and by saying he's like leading the Democratic
>> not going to fixate on the word cancel. The guilt by
association argument is the one that I don't think is going to
land for Democratic primary voters. I don't think they really
give a >> I I think they've struck paydirt with Hasan on
the right and I think they're going to double down and keep >> I
think it's very funny watching Dude, it's super funny to me watching
both Pisco and Soy Pill. The thing that them most in this entire
world is being accused of having one iota of sympathy for Hasan.
I don't even like Hasan. Uh excuse ME, I DON'T EVEN CAN I HAVE
I NOT criticized Hasan? Yes or no, have I criticized Hasan? I
don't even LIKE HASAN. WHY WOULD YOU WHY WOULD YOU SUGGEST THAT
I MIGHT LIKE HASAN? WHY WOULD YOU That's like the thing that
haunts them at night, okay? For other people, it's like regular
concerns. For these two, it's like, "Oh my god, some level of
association to Hasan? That's terrifying. Oh my god. It's bro
and and the and IRI and Hutch are totally fine to run their like
little narrative. And I do think it comes out a certain way.
And I'm not saying you say Hasan's, you know, a perfect liberal
who loves democracy. You don't have to say that. I don't I don't
believe that. You shouldn't believe that. That's not He He is
literally okay with like a post-liberal democracy. In fact, I
I believe he said it's his ideal would be a post-liberal democracy.
So, I I do think it's it's a little crazy that they're like they're
a little worried about doing any defense. They're a little little
Eventually that'll break. Eventually I know Pisco will break.
I don't know about Soy Bo.
I don't know. But Pisco will break. Pisco won't be able to like
listen to bad arguments for long for very long. He'll like kind
of lose it. >> So, we'll see what happens. I wouldn't be
surprised if foreign actors get involved and even the right makes
up stories about Hasan in order to keep that going cuz anything
that causes division on our side is great. So, they're they love
it. >> Well, he's got a lot riding on this election cycle
because Hasan's putting him himself out there in a way that he
he hasn't in the past. Like he's made tremendous efforts to raise
his national profile, raise his name recognition, and become
personally involved in political races. I mean, he was before
>> Which is good or bad, Hutch? Which is good or Cuz I
I feel like we got to we got to be consistent, all right? Cuz
I I know for a fact Hutch would be talk kind of all kinds of
[__] about how Hasan stays home, Hasan doesn't do
anything, Hasan's totally performed, right?
Is it good or bad that he's like trying to actually get involved?
>> not to this extent. And so, he is obviously trying to
occupy a lane within Democratic Party politics that has actual
real influence. And so, the first thing to look for would be
like with if Said would have dropped in the polls after all that
coverage, but he went up like seven points or something like
that. So, at least during these primaries, I don't think Hasan's
going anywhere, but if we get to the general and you know, we
get past these primaries and and most are most of the candidates
that he's supporting, you know, get whooped, then that drops
his stock quite a bit. He's going to get less phone calls. But
if you if his candidates do do well, then we're going to see
more of them in the years to come. So
>> So what would you like to >> I See, this is this
is like setting up a pre-framing, okay?
No. No. I always reject this. And I'm not saying this cuz I I'll
be honest. I don't particularly think that a lot of like a lot
of the socialist candidates to me, I feel like the conversation
should be had, but I'm looking at a different conversation that
should be had. I want like a meta discussion
on the concept of liberal democracy and whether it's capable
of acting quickly enough, of being agile enough to deal with
modern concerns. I want that conversation to be had more and
more and more, and anything I can talk about that lets me hammer
that point home, that I do not think the current liberal the
the
the general framework of the liberal democracy right now
effective in the world moving this fast, corporations moving
this fast, okay?
I need I need that conversation to be had, and right now we're
seeing people who are basically arguing for a form of
And I want them to do better. Because I think that's an important
conversation to have, okay? I want people who are basically saying
the status quo is not good enough. This managed decline is not
good enough. I want I will support those people. It's not accelerationism.
It's hey, I think
I don't want accelerationism. That's not that's not what I'm
saying. I'm saying there is some tweak needs to be made. We need
to start having this meta discussion, right? On what tweaks need
to be made so that decisions can be made faster, so that we have
some hope of of preventing the fall off of the cliff I think
is coming.
All right?
So I I'm not even going to say that I think Hassan This is by
the way, I'm super far. I've done like two sort of leaps here.
But I'm not not going to tell you that I want Hassan to like
win or his candidates to win. In fact, I think they will largely
lose. I and the framing Hutch is setting up is, well, if they
do really badly, that shows that there's no appetite for this.
That is not true. Okay? That is not true. Do not let them gaslight
you on this. They There's no indication that if you lose badly
in any of these elections,
okay? Look at the spending. Look at the ad buys that are going
to go into these elections to prevent these primary candidates
from being successful because they are terrified of this kind
of narrative. They're totally terrified. So, even if you lose
badly in some places because a candidate gets totally swamped,
gets totally outspent,
all right? And
>> and they don't win, don't get discouraged. That is not
an indication that your politics isn't working.
The indication that your politics is working is a flood of money
against you. That's the indication. That's your primary indicator,
your North Star. The more money they're spending against you
in terms of primaries, that is showing that you are resonating
with people and it scares them. It terrifies them. They're spending
more and more and more money to try to make up that gap that
they can't do with rhetoric. Okay?
So, never let people tell you that the reason the whole reason
that you're like, oh, that this is the litmus test right now
or sorry, that this is the test. This will tell us. This is the
experiment and we'll know after this. No, you won't know after
this. You
All right? This is This is years long. This is a years long thing.
This is not this cycle. This is not these midterms. It's not
even the next presidential
Don't stop. Don't get discouraged.
All
Don't do it. All right. So, that's how I feel about that. I don't
like the idea that this is like a one-time thing and it'll show
if they lose badly, it shows that you failed. That is not true
and it's meant to discourage you from further organizing, from
further in like investing and endeavoring to do things like Drop
Site or any organizing that you're doing. And don't let it work,
okay? Don't let that sort of um
Oh, what is it? Demoralization campaign affect you. Don't let
it Don't let it hit you, okay?
That's That's fear you're sensing. It's not loss, it's fear,
okay? On the other party's part. >> we're going to see
more of them in the years to come, so
So, what would you like to see? Do you if um Said wins the um
primary, would you like to see the success of him
uh, and thereby possibly
lead to um you know, a permission structure and a more viable
strategy for campaigning with with Hassan, or would you like
to see him lose so that he gets discredited?
>> I mean, I have my preference, but I'm not going to delude
myself, you know? Like, the fact that Said went up, I mean, the
other thing too is just like the fact that Fox News was covering
this so aggressively, it's like they did kind of give him free
press because they raised his national profile. Like, more people
know who Said is now. And so, like that, you know, especially
when you're only pulling in like 22%,
that could give you like a little bit of a bump. What's up in
the >> Uh, well, that seems really uncomfortable to me.
That seems like a really uncomfortable question, guys. >> Here
is >> Hold on. Does Hutch get it totally from the other
side? Is he basically going to argue exactly what I said, but
from the lib side, the more liberal side, the more like progressive,
the the incremental change side? Like, this is not Actually,
if he wins, that's not really going to mean much, actually. >> Fox
News was covering this so aggressively, it's like they did kind
of give him free press because they raised his national profile.
Like, more people know who Said is now. And so, like that, you
know, especially when you're only pulling in like 22%,
that could give you like a little bit of a bump. What's up in
the air is, you know, how much more room does he have to grow.
That's not
Pisco just asked if he won, what would you what would be your
prescription for liberals, for Democrats, if he wins? That's
literally not this. That's not the same
in this race. >> in a different direction. Has he hit sort
of the hard cap and we'll see in the next month here, but I mean,
>> said you had your preference, but your preference would
be that he would win if he's the Democratic nominee. >> If
he's the Democratic nominee, of course I'll endorse him and and
and I suggest that people vote for him, but during the primaries
I I I think Saagar is positioning himself as adversarial. Like
he's he's he's doing the thing that I was talking about earlier,
which is
he's framing himself as like opposition to the Democratic Party
from within the Democratic Party, and so I just I don't want
to see those kind of candidates win primaries personally. I don't
love that Platner's doing so well, so >> I I think that
the populist left, that sorry, the Fetterman
debacle has done a lot of damage to left-wing populists in this
country. >> Um the funny thing is
Oh man, the very funny thing is is like if you if you were to
do the Cenk
uh like the Cenk argument here, it's that these populists can
actually reach the center better than you. That like the way
you guys communicate doesn't actually hit the average person,
and someone like Glenn Platner, he's showing that he's hitting
the average person way more, and I think he's got a different
direction he can go in where he hits the average person like
way harder. The average person hears him speak, and they they
like get it, they feel it, right? That the way to the center
is not to moderate. The way to the center is to break the paradigm.
That they don't like the same thing they've been hearing. The
way to get those more undecided voters is to break the paradigm,
to be unique in some way, to actually say something that hits
people emotionally, that that resonates, okay? It's it's
it's like a different thing. This idea that the more moderate
we become, yeah, the more moderate you become, the more like
centrist voters like you. It's like, bro, the more the more we
sand off any sharp edge or any real position, the more voters
will like us. No, the less offensive they'll find you. But at
this
basically the the appeal to the drive to become less offensive
to everybody is the most offensive thing you could do to a lot
of people.
>> Um because I think that no matter what, if you have
a firebrand populist left-wing candidate, one question that's
going to be raised is no more fetterman's. Are you going to be
a fetterman or not? Um and I think that there's a lot of tentativeness
now um to in in terms of trust. And so that's one area where
I think
Senate Democrats who want to be more of this firebrand, who want
to be more like Bernie, less like >> I do feel like this
is the feeling I get is like actually and I can believe this
by the way. I can believe this and still think it's a really
dumb message. But it's almost like guys, actually 2016 Hillary
Clinton was like the best candidate. We should have we guys wasn't
Hillary awesome? We're going to be like more like Hillary. We're
just going to be We're going to be a party of Hillary Clinton.
And it's like dude, I understand that I do wish Hillary Clinton
had won the 2016 election, okay? And saved us from the world
nearly ending.
But she didn't.
And I there's a lot of fear and I have a lot of fear that that
just thinking that she was the way to to win more moderate people's
hearts, I it's not. It's not. It's not. It's just not.
Come on, man. >> Like Fetterman, I think they need to reestablish
trust and and show the Democratic constituency that they're not
going to be just another pack of >> Yep. Well, this would
be a good time to announce Hutch and I will be going to Michigan
to campaign for McMorrow. >> Oh, wow.
>> Oh, barely buried the lead on your >> That is
>> Wow. I that was crazy. That was a crazy thing to say.
That was a totally insane thing to say, okay? >> Wait,
that's cool. >> Are you joking?
>> Hutch is so confused. >> I think he's joking.
Yeah, I was like
>> I was like, how long did it take for you to say that?
>> I thought you were dead serious. I I still can't tell
if you're joking. >> I would do it. I definitely want to
see Hassan fall flat. But uh and it sucks that it has this candidate
may have to pay the price. but uh I do not want to see Hasan
get this sort of power and attention. I don't I do not think
he's good in the long run. >> We can't sacrifice what we
want to win because of someone we don't like endorse them, right?
I mean like >> Well, in the primary. >> If If you
liked I'll say I said I do think Israel's doing war crimes, but
unfortunately I got to go to somebody who's going to keep giving
them weapons because listen, Hasan endorsed the guy who's calling
out the war crimes and I don't know what to do about that. I
just really don't want Hasan to win.
That can't be the determining factor. >> I don't think
I don't think but IRI's like lived up like super lived up. I
don't think IRI would like El Sayed better in the first place.
I think El I think McMorris would have been like IRI's Stevens
might have been even closer to IRI what he would want, but McMorris
was plenty good for IRI. I do think he would want McMorris. >> factor
as to whether or not you'd want him to win, right? >> No, it
is. To me it's his judgment is way off teaming up with Hasan.
>> Oh, wow. >> So, it's a it's a judgment question.
>> That's a factor. >> huge Yeah, it's very problematic.
It seems to me a desperate attempt to
>> Wait, hold on. Hold on. You don't want him to win because
the judgment is bad, but if he won then the judgment wouldn't
be bad. Hello? The judgment would have been good if he wins.
If he was not going to win and then the judgment is bad because
you say actually uh he won, but I don't like that cuz his his
judgment What? Lost. I'm lost. Oh, the Hasan [__]
show is on. Sick. Well, they only did like 20 minutes of it today,
okay? They only did 20 minutes and there's some reasonable pushback
this time. I just I I thought that was cra- That's a crazy thing
to say. You could say I don't like You could say that he's only
saying that um well, I don't want him to win because or I don't
like that he went to Hasan at Oh, it's a desperate attempt. Actually,
you know what? Let's listen to this whole thing, but
I think he I think he had to do this. >> judgment is way
off teaming up with
>> Oh, wow. >> So, it's a it's a judgment question.
>> That's a factor. >> It's a huge Yeah, it's very
problematic. It seems to me a desperate >> Oh, please ask
why. Please just ask why. Please just No. No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. I need to know why What about teaming
up with this on makes the judgement bad? >> Great attempt
to rise above the fray. >> That's not it. >> And
it it just >> Seems like a desperate attempt to rise above
the fray.
That Basically, if you're behind in a three-way race, that's
smart.
It's obviously like a good judgement to make if you're rising
above the fray. You have to say why it's bad to team up with
this on. >> Man, it seems to me a desperate attempt to
rise above the fray.
And it it just
It just rubs me the wrong way. So, I think McMar- I think McMarro
is a great candidate. I like her a lot. So, it just to me it
pushes her away. >> sure. If it's like, okay, all sequel,
these are pretty close, and then this thing pushed me over the
edge. That's fine. But, I mean like if it was not close to me,
I I wouldn't take the endorsement of like, you know, David Duke
came in and was like, yeah, like let's go all say it. I'd be
like, that's really weird. You had a white nationalist >> not
campaigning with And listen, this is >> Yeah, it's not
an analog at all.
Yeah, that's true. >> Not to clip >> I said I said
uh bruh bruh
>> Never mind. Don't defend Hasan so I feel. Don't defend
Hasan. We're good. We're good, buddy. I can handle it. Pisco
can handle it. Just just sit on the sidelines for a second, okay?
>> I'm not saying that David Duke is equal to Hasan, all
right, folks? Clippers [laughter] Clippers out there. We're not
saying But, you would >> I don't think it's like something
that you shouldn't take into consideration who someone chooses
to campaign with. I mean, that that is >> It's not a relevant
factor. >> So, you you can take it into Dude, the Liz Cheney
thing was obviously something like lefties can't even be mad
about that. If you're just saying it looks bad, but I I already
didn't say that. I I I I said it was a bad judgement because
he tried to raise himself above the fray. Rise Rise above the
fray. He tried to like get ahead in the polls. That is literally
what campaigning is about. That's what politicking is. You're
trying to rise above the fray.
You can't say trying to politic and get voters on your side is
bad politics.
You have to say why you have some objection to his son's character.
You have to actually make a prescription, like why you don't
like him, why you think El Sayed is a bad person. Right? You
have to basically argue that although this is effective with
voters,
I think it's a moral it's a character
It's it's a bad judgment on the is a it's a character flaw. That's
where the bad judgment is. Not
Not in terms of the analysis that he might rise above cuz he
clearly has for one thing, and I think he's going to continue
to even if he doesn't win. Like it's clear that this helped small
>> the it's not the single thing that would push me over
the edge one way or the other, but it matters.
I on a macro level, I really want the sort of like Hassan wing
of Democratic Party politics to fail miserably in my in November,
but it's for good reasons. It's because I want them to like learn
a valuable lesson, and I want them to start paying
November's not literally the midterm elections. He means like
now for the primaries, right?
Wouldn't November isn't November the the actual midterm elections?
Or when were those Yeah, you don't want them to fail in
You basically just said you want Platner to lose, which I think
is actually hinting at your underlying motive here, but that's
like an insane thing to say.
Like you you literally you're the blue no matter who guy and
you're you're literally say dude, my brain my brain.
My god.
That's that's a wild thing to say. Yeah, I maybe will somebody
call him on it? >> in my in November, but it's for good
reasons. It's because I want them to like learn a valuable lesson,
and I want them to start paying attention to Mondani more in
terms of like how to do politics and how
how to do politics and
>> By Wait, what did Mondani do? I think Mondani ran like
a further left campaign that he was going to like actually govern,
probably because of, you know, restrictions. But the campaign
was effective. So why are you against them running the campaign
that way? I don't get it. I don't I don't get it. >> Right
now, they seem
very emboldened in a way that I don't think I've ever seen. Um
I don't think that their evaluation of the current moment is
Wait. >> Actually, hold on. Hold on. I didn't I didn't
even think to say this. Hold on. >> like learn a va- Democratic
Party [clears throat] politics to fail >> Dude, hold on.
I got to go back and do the whole thing. Again, we got to take
another run at this cuz holy You guys are making a good point,
chat. Just give me a second. >> It's not the it's not the
single thing that would push me over the edge one way or the
other, but it matters.
>> I, on a macro level, I really want the sort of like
Hasan Wing of Democratic Party politics to fail miserably in
my in November, but
>> In November being the actual general election for the
midterms, meaning, I guess we just want the the lefties to lose.
We want MAGA to win to own the lefties, guys.
That's an insane thing to say. Maybe a Freudian slip, maybe a
mix-up. I'm not totally sure, okay? But that's already insane.
But wait, it does get better. >> It's It's for good reasons.
It's because I want them to like learn a valuable lesson, and
I want them to start paying attention to Mondani Moore in terms
of >> Oh, hold on. Mondani Moore, hold on.
Wait. They You want them to learn from Mondani? Like
Like wait. Like
Like this Mondani?
Like Like this guy? Like this?
You want them to learn a lesson, a valuable lesson from Zoran
K. Mamdani.
All right? Apparently,
Hutch is Wait, I Hutch, you're sending mixed messages. What lesson
exactly do you want them to learn from Zoran Mamdani? I just
want them to take a page out of Zoran's book. How about this
page, Hutch? What do we think about this page? Would this page
Would this page be good? I feel like this page would be, you
know, maybe this page not so bad.
What do we think?
That's a totally insane thing to say.
Dude, I just WANT THEM I WANT THEM to fail. I want them to take
a page from
The topic is literally that you shouldn't campaign with Assad.
Zoran campaigned with Assad.
Cool. All right. Okay. All right. I
This show is special. This show is very, very special. You love
You love to see All right, let's uh I think we're close to finishing
up here. Like >> how to do politics. And right now, they
seem
very emboldened in a way that I don't think I've ever seen. Um
I don't think that their evaluation of the current moment is
grounded in reality. Like they do seem to think that there is
a massive kind of surge
of their kind of politics all over the country. And they selectively
pick
>> The massive surge of their kind of politics is seen
in Donald Trump winning an election in 2024
after trying to steal the 2020 election. That's the massive surge
in their politics. They are just trying to say that you guys
are the party of of like uh what is it um of slow and steady
decline? You guys are the party of like just basically manage
it rearranging deck chairs on the Titanic? You guys are the party
of
And that even if they're lying, the Republicans are trying to
paint like some vision on how things could change. And you're
just like, "No, things are really good." But nobody thinks things
are really good. And if you're going to run on a thing on a on
a platform of, "Well, weren't things great under Biden and we'll
go back to like just, you know, slow incremental change, steady,
repetitive decline and we'll be all good, guys. You're not going
to talk about any of the big issues, any of the massive icebergs
facing your country and broadly the planet. We're not going to
talk about any of that. We're just going to be like, guys, listen,
if we just build like 5% more housing, we really solve a lot
of problems.
I don't think I don't think anybody feels that way. And I'm not
saying burn it down, but you got to actually talk about what's
Why unemployment continues to rise, why the economy is in the
sh- why it's not likely that it will recover in the near
Somebody has to talk about it, right? Surely we can't all enter
this totally derealized state with this the state where nothing
is real, nothing we can't actually evaluate the world. And that's
what they're arguing. They are arguing for Soviet-era hypernormalization
of the current state. Like basically saying, "No, things are
great, aren't they?" as they continuously decline.
No. No. No. No. No.
I I think there's still some hope. Not a not a big hope. I'm
I'm basically like
a small percentage. That like some little change could be made,
but if you're not willing to talk about the problems, you're
never going to gradually fix the problems.
You have to be able to You have to be able to discuss what the
problems are for you to be able to fix them.
All right. Old Hasan tweet, but sorry, old Zoran tweet, but funny.
Let's Let's check it out. What is this? What is this? What is
this? Those are Socialist candidates can win all over the country
because the working class exists all over the country. Congratulations
to all with special love from CMK Shama, a giant wall a giant
of the left and champion of working people. Queens beat Amazon
and so will Seattle.
Okay, let's go. Socialist candidates can win all over the country
because of the working the working class exists all over the
country. That's what I I say. Guess who's Guess who's voting
against you Democrats?
It's the working class and you're never going to be able to show
them a graph that GDP went up like point four percent under Biden
over expectations and so he's really the he was listen Dems had
the all the right ideas. It's just not going to work.
It's I really don't believe it will work. Anyway,
well, well
let's I I keep thinking we're done but we're we've not been done
so >> kind of high-profile races and ignore the kind of
quiet normie Dems that are just like very quietly murdering Republicans
by like 30 points but you know, they see the polls of the Democratic
Party approval being so low and they see approval for Israel
being so low and I think they take that as
a validation of like their philosophy
and I think that it's like a correlation not causation kind of
situation here
>> Oh, that's totally true. Hutch has finally said something
sane. The it isn't a validation of socialist economics that people
have turned on
It is a validation of the approach they took the attention they
drew their their outrage their anger it's validation of that
it's not a validation of like socialist economics or speaking
like in terms of populist economics speaking to the working class
it's not a validation of their worldview but it is absolutely
a validation of like hey Israel's bad and guess who can't say
that in unison as a party. Well, actually both parties but the
parties of gradual change right that they're so set in their
ways they're incapable of acknowledging the reality in front
of them at any with any alacrity whatsoever. They have to hedge
constantly. They can never ever call a spade a spade and that's
starting to wear thin on every single person on the planet. Okay.
It just is and every what is it dude? There's oh man. What is
the is it an MLK saying those who make peace impossible make
violence inevitable those who make equality impossible make violence
inevitable something like this. There's like a way of describing
the idea that if things are broken, things aren't
and you refuse to acknowledge that or make or even hint towards
change. If things are truly broken, you make some kind of like
violence, some kind of revolutionary ideas inevitable. I believe
that. That you have to start talking about this stuff.
You got to. Even if it's a meta conversation about like, "Hey,
maybe cuz technology is such a big thing." I think if you start
with the meta conversation, which a lot of people have had this,
but it seems to have disappeared. "Hey, we're not updating fast
enough with technology."
That speaks to a foundational weakness of liberal democracies.
They cannot update fast enough to keep up with technology. If
you let these technological gains for corporations that have
that have shareholders and are not beholden to any government,
if you let these technological gains compound over long enough
a long enough period of time, they will outpace the actual citizenry
of the United States, the government of the United States, in
some
So, I think that's where it starts. I think that's where you
basically get at the weakness of liberal democracy right now
is through technology.
I think. Been thinking about it a little bit. I I That seems
to be where you start to tug at the thread.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll keep >> There's not a lot of
strong evidence
that they're kind of like positioned to
take over the party right now. And what does it say about their
movement when that is their goal?
And they don't really seem to be positioned well to do that despite
the fact that the Democratic Party approval rating is at historic
lows. Like if now is if there was ever a time to take over the
party, now would be it. Also,
you have to accept when you lose. And every time that wing loses,
they just blame cheating and that it's not their candidate failed.
It's always something was rigged and they they had it the deck
>> This is
It's true on both sides. So, what our I saying is is true. That
people are willing to make all kinds of excuses when they lose.
and it's you know, APAC money, all of the things, right? But
also those things happen. And there is going to be um like there
is going to be institutional friction towards your candidates.
You will have to overcome that.
Right? It's never going to go away until you start winning significantly.
It's not going away. You're not even close yet to having like
enough clout, enough of of of a power base to stop that institutional
friction. You have to overwhelm it. Yes, but transnational capital
can't be a threat unless they reach some sort of like technological
parity or military militaristic parity with the US. Ultimately,
the US has the tools to solve the transnational capital problem.
Orderbeller, I think.
But but I think that at least the US does. No other country does,
but at least the US does.
it's tough to know cuz I man, if you if you're to get to I'm
just thinking in my head like what if China starts I there's
a lot of different dominos here. I wonder if anybody really has
a good handle on that system, like what would happen. Like let's
say hypothetically they decide to put a a big wealth tax in the
US, start start like taking shares from companies. Does everything
just explode? Like what where do those companies generate value?
How do they generate value? How do you how can these things move?
Where where can that capital go ultimately that their assets
are protected? I'm not sure. I I'm sure there's like videos on
it like schizos who are at least like putting the dots together.
Like basically the transnational capital is going to flee here,
here, and here. Like if it goes to China, I think China has enough
production, enough capacity that you're not going to be able
to like do anything to China.
There would be reasons not to go there and also like all the
value in the companies in the US stock market.
So I yeah, I don't know. Man, it's it's one of those things where
it's like when you audit everything,
who holds the cards? Who's got who's got the leverage? I don't
know.
In any case, it's it's basically always come down to it doesn't
matter who has the leverage because
US military exists.
That's what it's been for like what, 70 years now?
60, sorry, 80 years now, essentially.
Never mattered.
I disagree. As long as nation states can compete on tax and labor
costs, the US alone cannot solve this. Um hmm.
No, I'm saying that the US would have to be world police at that
point. The US would start enforcing this. Right? That the US
would use their the threat of their military. This is why I joke
that like I don't want to waste munitions in Iran that are going
to need be needed for Switzerland.
Like I I wish they'd stop wasting munitions in Iran cuz they're
going to be required for Switzerland.
Okay? Is the kind of thing I'm saying.
Like you need the actual military might of the US.
And so that's why I've always said that I don't think um a military
build-up is actually a bad idea, like the high Pentagon budgets.
I don't actually think it's a high a bad idea. I think the US
military is going to be need to be strong no matter where where
the future goes.
For the sake of like I don't know, uh human happiness.
Yeah, I'm hitting play. >> stacked against them, and to
me that's no better than MAGA. I mean, that's Donald Trump. Like
our democracy
>> No, no, no, it's not a military economy. It's the idea
that the US doesn't even produce anything.
And the US dollar is the world reserve currency because the US
has the military that could actually enforce freedom of navigation
and this global just-in-time manufacturing sphere we The US military
is the only one that could do it, the US Navy. Right? And so
people do allow the US to basically get away with not producing
anything and only doing financial services and just betting on
things. They're we're like gambling North America broadly is
gambling and off in a corner, okay? While the rest of the world
dances to their tune. Anyway, keep going. >> requires you
to admit when you lose and
and accept it and fight. >> I guess there's research. There's
research in America, too. There's research, as well. There is
research. There is like technological innovation. It's not nothing.
It's not nothing. It's not nothing. I shouldn't minimize it that
much. It's not production though. It's not like making widgets.
It's not making military equipment. It's not making things. It's
It's financial might and it's It's technological advancement.
Okay? >> Live to fight another day and I don't get that
vibe from that group. Like if if that guy that Hassan endorses
loses, Hassan will claim everything except that he ran a He didn't
run as good of a campaign as he should have. >> Well, I
do want to say on the last point, the deck is stacked against
people that are not in the majority. But that's the reality of
politics. And you're if you're unable to navigate that, if like
you know people say, "Oh, all the candidates dropped out and
that made Bernie Sanders lose on after Super Tuesday." It's like,
"Okay, well, what was going to happen if you had one and all
the candidates say, 'Well, I don't want to pass your policy,
right?'" Like that's part of working in politics. So, I I don't
>> Hold on. It's It's the idea that it's fair. The I think
leftists do have to reckon or do have to understand that it's
not ever going to be fair. You will have to be overwhelming.
If you If you want even not even like leftism like socialism
or something, if you just want even populace to win. Like like
Platner. I don't I don't know if Platner's like a truly dyed-in-the-wool
socialist of any kind. Seems very much more like a populist.
Like sort of a Cenk Uygur type of populist, okay?
But if you want If you want to win, you want your candidates,
they need to be overwhelming. It can't be like oh, we're running
a very close campaign until the last moment cuz every single
coin flip you're going to do at the end where money goes, where
decision-making on on any sort of regulation goes, where endorsements
go last minute, where endorsements could flip last minute, every
single one of those coin flips that seem like a coin flip scenario
is going to go against you and you're going to get destroyed
via by them, okay? You're going to lose because of them. And
just just get ready cuz not only that, but if you win these primaries,
get ready for the Hutch types, okay? Whether I'm not sure if
Hutch misspoke or what happened there. But with the Hutch types,
okay?
Get ready in November
for these people to work against you. The way they worked against
Mondaire, okay? Get ready for that. It's going to
That's why you got to be overwhelming. Cuz you you aren't going
to get blue no matter who. Blue no matter who is them trying
to break you into following whatever they want.
And I but at the same time you should vote for Democrats over
Republicans, especially until the Republican Party has some major
schism or change. Republicans are evil. But the blue no matter
who stuff broadly is not something they're saying like we're
going to support blue no matter who. It's saying, well, we'll
talk to you, but you have to support our candidates after you
lose. No matter what happens. No matter how badly we we wrapped
you, you have to support our candidates. That's what they're
trying to say to you, okay? >> All right. I don't think
that's unfair to call out, but that's a frustration that you
can air and then figure out a way to work in the system cuz you
can't just you know, you hear about that every time and then
realize that you know, nothing's going to change. You're never
going to get elected if you can't work with the people that aren't
as progressive as you. >> Let me ask Pisco. I'm actually
curious what you think about this. Did Did if Hassan's guy doesn't
win, do you think Hassan will say, well, we just we didn't run
as good of a campaign. We could have done better. Or will he
start blaming
>> No, but hold on. The going to going to
That's Pisco should answer this question by saying, wait, if
things do flip that don't lean into like this being a fair thing
where it's just a battle of ideas. If there's some kind of rap
going on or if there's a massive shifts in capital to advertise
against Ayanna and attack
you think they shouldn't point that out? You think it should
be incumbent on them to let themselves get and then roll over
and let you like and show them like collectively show you their
belly? That's you have to ask that question cuz I do believe
that's broadly what the And if that's the agreement, then just
come to the agreement, right? Like yeah, basically we're going
to do everything we can to stop you, including like some stuff
that seems to be against our principles. And we still want you
to vote for us in the general election. That's that's how you
should hear this
And I think you should be willing to make that trade. It's like,
okay, I know it's not going to be fair. I know it's uphill. And
you can point it out, but you got to be a little careful about
how you point it out after, is what they're looking for. Anyway,
we continue. >> and say it was rigged and all this
>> No, no, but I think that has more to do with like the
personality type of Hold on. Again, I'm going to go back here.
We're going to We're going to listen again to I I asked this
question, but I do want to answer this question or comment on
this real quick. The mainstream Hassan discourse is the rap attempt.
Just so they're they're just so disconnected that it's effectiveness
it's got effectiveness wrong. They got its effectiveness wrong.
Sure. Yes, but I'm telling you it will get worse. I'm telling
you if El-Sayed were to win in Michigan, you can fully expect
Michigan Democrats to endorse the Republican candidate. You can
fully expect like powerful political brokers in Michigan to support
the Republican candidate. You can expect some federal politicians
to withhold their endorsement. You you expect this. It will happen,
okay?
I'm telling you even in the general election, it will not be
blue no matter who if El-Sayed wins.
I'm very skeptical to think it'll even be blue no matter who
with Platner. And I think Platner, by virtue of not directly
campaigning with with Hassan,
I like he's probably a little less extreme. Although he's also
got that Nazi tattoo thing, so it's hard to say. So, just expect
that. That is going to
Okay? The rap he's not done. It will continue. You got to push
through it. You got to win through it. >> didn't run as
good of a campaign. We could have done better. Or will he start
and say it was rigged and all this
>> No, no, but I think that has more to do with like the
personality type of Hassan than it does of
>> But that's why I want him out of our politics, because
to me that's no better than Trump saying, you know, I didn't
lose the election. It was stolen from >> Wait, I just I
want I want Trump out of our politics and I want like
the question isn't like what in a perfect world would Hassan
be in our politics or out of our politics? In some ways, right?
Like we can't effectuate
the deplatforming or the removal of Hassan from the Democratic
interactions. Like that's not something we have the power to
do. So, the question becomes like what are we analyzing? Who
are we analyzing? So, when we say they think X, they think Y,
I might agree with you if they include
>> Why won't they release the autopsy? The answer to that
is basically in the lobbying, right?
Look at the Third Way article. That's the answer to that.
I'm telling you you have to know this in your heart that your
politics are winning. They are reaching the average person far
better. They being Democrats here, obviously. Don't joke around,
guys.
this this is the case, right? That that is they are scared of
this of this type of politics. They are terrified of it. That's
why they won't release the autopsy, right? That's why when we
went into that election, and again, I I think my my decision
to move away from politics was a huge mistake in retrospect.
I think I think if I'd been writing my ideas down from that election,
cuz the people who watch the stream know, but I was saying the
it's the economy, the economy's bad, you guys are going to lose
on the economy. And everybody hated that idea. Whenever I brought
it up, people would push back. They'd be so angry about me saying
it. And it's so clear that that's everything. That was everything
in that election.
That people thought Trump would be better. Now, Trump wouldn't
be better. Trump was dogged Trump's awful. But it's about the
economy again. And it's the macro direction of the economy, how
it is not working for the person in America and Canada and the
entire world right now.
And that conversation has to be had. And the people who talk
about that conversation, the people who have that conversation,
will reap benefits, okay? Biden is so good at the economy and
the most progressive president ever and totally cogent and electable,
don't you know? Yeah, exactly. His cost five instead of one,
I'm voting Trump. Yeah.
Um I just I regret not continuing, cuz I feel like I was vindicated
in a lot of the way I viewed things.
I regret not like writing stuff down and and doing more politics,
having more vlogs out about it. >> It would be kind of
like that and all lefties that we see online, but they also includes
the 30% or whoever the voter base is that's going to vote for
us say it. And all most of them I think are not like some of
their thought leaders or some of the people who we like who call
us names online. So I just think that we need to be very careful
about who we're analyzing there. >> Well, the the process
of deciding whether or not Hassan is a viable kind of asset for
the Democratic Party, that's essentially democratized. Like the
voters will decide that really. Like if if he runs the board
and like all of his endorsed candidates do really well, then
he's not going anywhere. It doesn't matter what Third Way thinks.
Like it doesn't matter like what kind of input they get. >> That's
what I mean. Yeah. What I mean What I mean to say is Yeah. Like
like he might win and we have to like Or when I say he, I'll
say it might win and it's going to be our job to support that
candidate. And I think that we should. And I don't think that
we should
um you know, conflate everyone who we don't like and everyone
who is with the people that those people support. Or when I say
he, I'll say it might win and it's going to be our job to support
that candidate. And I think that we should. And I don't think
that we should like um you know, conflate everyone who we don't
like and everyone who is bad faith with the people that those
people >> I got I got to say that he's I think you're wrong.
Like I think you said that that that that that instinct to kind
of blame external
You said you you chalked it up to to like Hassan's personality.
I don't think that's true. I think that's this is endemic to
that movement. I mean, when have you ever seen
a more kind of far lefty can >> I'm just telling you I
I understand like they're trying to say you shouldn't complain
about it.
This isn't going to work. It's actually an extension of the other
stuff. I think I would appreciate lefties framing the complaints
correctly.
And yeah, we we're like I think I have the right tone. You have
to be overwhelming. You every every little thing that can go
wrong will go wrong for you. It's like you're basically going
to the Olympics in China and you're like trying to win in figure
skating against Chinese figure skaters. It's like you listen,
unless you are transcendental,
you are going to lose. Every tiny thing that will go against
you can can go against you will go against you. You can imagine
it's Russia, too, if you really like China, okay?
Every single thing will go against you. Every little ticky-tack
thing they can do will go against you. So, you have to be overwhelming.
And if you're not overwhelming, you do have to swallow your pride
a little bit and vote for their candidate even if they you. You
have to you have to vote Democrat even if they you cuz it is
consequential. The managed decline is better than whatever the
Republicans are offering, okay?
is until there's a insane change on the Republican side. They're
like off the ballot entirely for you. That's how everybody should
be messaging here, in my opinion. >> And then did a left
populist candidate lose an election and then not blame
the donors, the system, you know, the media. Like >> I
got to shut her a little. What did we blame for Kamala's loss?
Was it Kamala?
>> We don't rewrite
Oh my god. Hutch is destroyed.
Hutch is destroyed. Hutch is wrecked. Hutch is wrecked. >> What
did we blame for Kamala's loss? >> Hutch is destroyed.
We love soy pill again. We've gone back and forth on soy pill
on this stream, okay? We loved him, then we hated him, now we
love him again, all right? Let's go. >> Don't rewrite history
on this one. Were you on the podcast when she >> He knows
he's so caught. He knows he's so caught and he's doing the exact
same
I please I swear to god if he if Hutch does the same excuses
that they would do, oh what am I not supposed to say the truth?
That's crazy.
>> We don't rewrite
>> He's like a child with his cookie caught in the cookie
jar. Literally, this is when you catch your like 4-year-old brother
with his with his hand in the cookie jar and he like, "You know
you're not supposed to do that." And he like looks at you and
smiles, like he knows he just got caught, he's doing something
wrong. He knows it. You got him. You got him, okay?
So, he built he knows he got you. They they got you, okay? >> history
on this one. Were you on the podcast when she lost? I mean, we
talked about her failings as a >> candidate for months,
you know? Like we >> want to say this is, you know, we
do this too. >> I Hutch, if we look at your tweets, are
we going to find you blaming Kamala Harris for her losses most
of the
Or am I going to see you going after lefties all over Twitter
all the freaking time
trying to hit them on oh, you you refused to endorse, you you
refused to support her, you refused Come on, man. Just be serious.
Just be real, dog.
Sick Monkey Chamber, thank you for the 20 months. Appreciate
it, man. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> Libs do this,
too. >> That's not true. >> It was the economy, she
didn't have enough time, [clears throat] and that's true, but
I don't know. We can't just pretend like this is like a specific
coalition of of lefties that do that, you know? >> I don't
agree. I think like when liberal candidates lose, you do see
way more
endless commentary about all the ways that they could have run
better
>> Hutch is actually
a Bernie bro except for lefties, right? Hutch is like talking
about how [__] over Kamala got and he's never going
to let it go. He's going to hold on it to it for like three cycles
with how [__] over Kamala was by the left. He's literally
just a Bernie bro, but he's a liberal Bernie bro.
Unironically, like he's just sitting here being like, "They They
[__] over They ruined it. They ruined everything.
I'll never trust them again." Right? He's just He's just Chank.
He's just a different flavor of Chank right now. He's about to
form
about to form Injustice Democrats, okay? >> You know, there
was some kind of like blaming Russia in 2016, and you know, there
was honestly like some kernel of truth to that. Um >> How
much does the honesty matter? If the cuz they if they if he even
gets near and I'd say this is basically it. You get near while
telling the truth shouldn't be a problem. Then you've lost every
single argument about these people endorsing your candidates
and not being mad about Gaza. You've lost them all. And I understand
that that's the normal human reaction, right? What am I not supposed
to complain about this? >> But you know, there was also
a lot of conversations about her neglecting like the Rust Belt.
>> Also a lot of blaming Comey though and Comey deserves
some blame there. Right? I I understand that in the >> Wait,
before you clarify. External forces matter.
If you only blame those every single time, you lack internal
critique. But I don't think this is like an exclusive thing to
the left. That's all I'm
>> Yeah, obviously it exists on the right, too. And um
it's so so the question is like are liberals above that? Are
liberals above cope and seething that things are And the answer
is no, we're not above that. Whether that's in terms of the Electoral
College and if that's in terms of Comey. That's not to say that
we are just as like lack the same set of self lack of self-awareness
as some people on who are on the farthest left or whatever. But
I just don't know what the
>> I'm back. I'm back. I'm back. Dude, I just realized
as I walked away, I just
you know what this is? You know what this is? >> I don't
think this is like an exclusive thing to the left. That's all
I'm
>> I don't think this is the exclusive thing to the left.
I think
this is the Kilo-tonics
mind control working working its magic. This is the Kilo-caball
as as coming to Soy Pill's DMs and made unquestionably
better arguments than anybody else and Soy Pill has slowly absorbed
these arguments through Kilo and he's ready to now fight on the
side of truth and justice, okay? Thank you so much Kilo for teaching
Soy Pill the way.
On behalf of me personally as I sent you out to do, as was your
mission, thank you, Kilo. I appreciate it, Soy Pill.
I didn't have enough faith. I didn't have enough faith in you
or Kilo, okay? >> Obviously, it exists on the right, too.
And um so the question is like are liberals above that? Are liberals
above Cope and seething that things are And the answer is no,
we're not above that. Whether that's in terms of the Electoral
College and if that's in terms of Comey. That's not to say that
we are just as like lack the same set of self lack of self-awareness
[snorts] as some people on who are on the farthest left or whatever.
But I just don't know what the analysis is. It's like they are
coping in a way that we never would.
>> The analysis is that then like my point is that the
reason why I want them to spectacularly fail and while at the
same time I'm Donny
succeeds in his role as mayor is because I want them to have
to be incentivized to like look to him to model their future
political strategy. Cuz right now what they're doing is basically
anyone outside of their politics are, you know, like adversaries.
Even within the Democratic Party. And you know, to be fair that
goes both ways. Obviously, like there's a lot of jabs at, you
know, the left from liberals, but they are um And and and when
they lose they don't to to Soy Pill's point like to my point
that I guess he was trying to refute is they seem incapable of
internal critique. Like they don't, you know, I never saw any
discussions about Bernie's
struggles with particular demographics. Like that almost like
that never came up. It was all you know, still to this day 2016
and 2020. That entire
that entire like ecosystem blame like the establishment for Bernie's
loss. And they don't they don't ask why he >> I will say
this is not
Bernie losing that primary is entirely on name recognition.
There's a reason they had to coalesce against Bernie to win in
the second >> in 2020.
yeah, there's there's a reason they had to coalesce behind a
candidate, right? They were getting blown the [__]
out.
And then 2024, they didn't have to worry about it cuz they could
just run I I'm honest I'm honest-to-goodness
at this point there's a tiny part the conspiratorial part of
me wonders in the back of my
how much was Biden running again about not having an open primary?
I a little part of me a little part of me wonders that like,
"Hey, we don't really want to take the pulse on this. We know
he's not fit, but we don't want to take the pulse on it cuz we
don't like where the pulse is at." There's like a little tiny
part of me I wonder if it wasn't a part of if it I don't think
it would have been a part of Joe Biden's calculus. I think in
terms of how things move behind the scenes in terms of like power
brokers and stuff, who's going to get supported and what the
decisions were made. Right? A little part of me is like, "Man,
I bet some people were like, 'Hey, we don't want an open primary.
We don't want to see what the public wants right now.'" I said
the same today. There's a little conspiratorial part of me that
wonders >> as popular cuz I didn't see this until very
recently, but like there's a lot of people in like black communities
talk about his inability to reach out and connect with a lot
of these places in like South Carolina and like how he just wasn't
prepared for the >> Hey, but let's be real. We all watched
the hot sauce
It's not like Hillary Clinton was a world beater in terms of
reaching out in these communities. She just had massive name
recognition.
And realistically in the black community, I'm almost positive
that it was just her husband. Like literally her husband being
an aspect of her campaign, everybody's like, "Yeah, we like this
guy. This guy is pretty cool." Hillary was not reaching out to
these people. It was just name recognition and dude, it's a it
gets a little crazy to me. It really is about name recognition.
>> coalition building that you saw with Joe Biden and Jim
Clyburn and that sort of stuff. So, it definitely happens, but
you're right, it's not super prevalent. Most people are it's
rigged, you know. >> I think I think Joe Biden would be
good at outreach. I think Joe Biden, when he's campaigning, could
be somebody who could talk to black communities.
That was corn pop story and everything. I think Joe Biden seems
like a guy who could reach those communities. Hillary? Nah. Nah.
Hillary Hillary got the vote because she was the wife of Bill
Clinton. Not joking. In in terms of the southern states where
it was like a big race split. I Oh, and her obviously being in
the Obama admin. Maybe more of the Obama
than anything. >> DNC favored him. That's the only reason
his ideas are the most popular. So, I know what you mean. There
is a lot of a >> Well, that brings >> But the just
to be clear, the DNC did favor certain candidates in 2016. Certainly
2016. Um so, like the question
did they favor certain candidates in 2016? Certainly 2016.
So, like
what the hell?
>> Hutch doesn't think so. Hutch doesn't think the DNC
favored a certain candidate in 2016.
The Democratic establishment absolutely
They absolutely favored a candidate. Why are we pretending otherwise,
man? It's silly. It's just silly. >> Certainly 2016. Um
so, like the question >> They used that as like the only
thing. Like it's like that's why that was the decision. Not because
he wasn't a popular enough. >> Yeah. The DNC is a >> Any
votes he did get would be largely via his rhetoric and policies.
Not because of his personality or his his name recognition. Like
his policies and the politics he was running on spoke to people.
They were going to be popular. They are popular now. And like
it's hard not to look back and just go, "Yeah, this guy was right
about a lot of Right? The the policies are popular now.
It's not that he was wrong or his policies were bad. It's that
he didn't have a name recognition and he was getting smeared
as a socialist, communist, whatever.
And those were the things that held him back. It's not
Like they're arguing, "Well, your pop your policies aren't popular."
Wrong. Wrong. Wrong. Wrong.
And as things get worse, you'll see it more and more. >> They
represent a political party and and and to the extent like so
what they did wrong in terms of like a breach of ethics was they
violated a rule that was in their charter that basically mandated
impartiality from the chair and it was the chair's responsibility
to make sure that the staff were impartial as well. And that
clearly wasn't the case. When you read the emails, you know,
they obviously favored Hillary Clinton. The crucial context to
all that was that those emails >> No, we haven't done that
yet, you >> basically every single one of the ones that
were like very embarrassing and damning and showed that bias
were written after Super Tuesday. And so in that context, you
have to understand that you know, Hillary had already essentially
locked that thing up and Bernie decided to stay he and >> I
I >> announced that he was going to stay into the race
until the convention to try to you know, push her left on on
policy.
And the media played up that race as though it was still like
anyone's ballgame and it wasn't. And his I think his support
>> They did not play it up as anyone's ballgame. In fact,
the most consequential part of that election for the DNC was
that I believe they did they not abolish superdelegates after
that or change how superdelegates worked that they wouldn't be
counted until their endorsement was given? They changed somehow
super the way superdelegates worked because what happened was
and the argument was the whole time that as long as the mainstream
media is showing the superdelegate difference, it's going to
seem pointless and impossible for Bernie to win. So nobody will
go and go out and vote in elections in primary elections, right?
Like that is that is the argument from 2016. And I'm not saying
that that's unfair. Like it was the way it worked before that.
But it did work against him significantly and it does show like
some level of institution institutional buying for Hillary and
against him. Effectively against him if not actually against
him, but for >> Orders thought that he still had a chance
and that chance completely evaporated on March 1st of 2016. And
so, you know, did they did demonstrate favoritism behind the
scenes? Like, yes, but how did that prevent Bernie from winning?
Like, how did that give Hillary an advantage during that primary?
>> I don't think that you heard any contradiction with
what we said with that. I mean, we're I'm not taking the view
that the DNC was the butt for cause of Bernie losing in 2016.
>> It was not. It was not. He was going to lose that no
matter what, unfortunately.
Kind of but he was always going to lose no matter how much better
his rhetoric was. Unless like sorry, he was always going to lose
as Bernie Sanders. If he was a totally different human who is
capable of throwing elbows and being like an actual like willing
to set the world on fire, willing to set the entire establishment
Democratic Party on fire to win like Trump was, he maybe he's
got a shot. I think he I think he's got an outside shot there,
but you have to throw elbows, you have to talk constantly talk
Hillary Clinton, you have to like be ready to burn the whole
thing down. And realistically, I don't think it was even the
wrong choice for him not to do that because of what an outside
shot it was. He's not the kind of narcissist Like, if he was
that kind of person, you actually wouldn't want him to be the
You know what I'm saying? Like, if you're that kind of person
who's willing to burn that whole party down, burn burn that whole
movement down to aggrandize yourself to be the guy in charge,
then you're not a good person. You shouldn't even be winning.
>> But I don't think it was like totally impossible. But
all that's being expressed and I think that you just acknowledged
is the DNC did favor Hillary Clinton. And I think it strains
credulity to think that that favoritism >> started whatever
date you were suggesting. The favoritism, I think, is just based
on who Bernie is and it predates sort of Super Tuesday. Unless
you're saying like, "Oh, only after when those emails happened,
that's when the preference developed." No, the preference is
developed >> Well, they had emails going back to January.
And the only the only emails that that that came out in terms
of like the major tranches that were showing favoritism were
all dated after after Super Tuesday. >> Whether there are
emails that like show favoritism after Super Tuesday is different
than whether the preference existed before then. You might even
say that it's a rational preference to have over Bernie Sanders
that in the same way that like the RNC probably didn't want Trump
to win, you know, and there were a lot of institutional forces
against Trump in the 2016 primary process. You might even say
it's a justified, uh, you know, I don't know, immune system of
the DNC had. Um, I don't know that I agree with that, but I I
think it's strange to do that to say, "Oh, no, the first time
they had a preference for Hillary was after Super Tuesday when
she lost." >> I I wish they'd stop like honestly Hutches
gaslighting is so counterproductive on every level. Like it's
not good to do this gaslighting in the first place and this lie
it's actually very it's there's a strange parallel to this I
could not think if I think about it in that like actually I don't
even know that every lefty necessarily wants you to not try to
protect liberal candidates or something. Like I think they assume
that's going to happen. It's when you tell them it's never happened,
it's never going to happen, but it still happens over and over
again. I think that's what's really it's not the only thing.
People will still be mad, but it sure hurts when you look at
somebody in the face and say there wasn't even anything working
against Bernie in 2016.
It just it it kills your credibility. It just don't gaslight.
But Pisco's hitting the line just right, right? Yeah, it's like
there was things there were things working against him, but he's
probably losing it even if they weren't. I feel like it's pretty
obvious he was losing it even if those things weren't working
against him, but they were and we shouldn't have those or you
know, you make the argument for why it's a a thing that makes
sense.
Yeah, you're just lying to people. Yeah, you just you're like
treating people like they're idiots. People don't like to be
treated like they're idiots. They are idiots broadly, but they
don't like to be treated that way. >> Locked it in. I don't
know if I'm >> demonstrated the the preference. Like it's
there's nothing wrong with working for the DNC and having an
internal preference that she win, but they they violated the
charter by demonstrating that preference in like an official
official email correspondence,
but you know, that doesn't translate to you know, them
forcing voters to, you know, like they didn't brainwash
>> which Hutch which Pisco just said. So, you're making
up some This is like
Dude, I I need to maybe find a way to say things outside of analogy,
but it's very much like
What do you When you say Bibi Netanyahu
vince Trump to go to war, do you mean he like controlled him
with blood magic? No. No, nobody thinks that. No, it's diplomacy,
like standard diplomacy that countries engage in all the time.
It's just relentless diplomacy only in one direction that's never
going to be paid back to the United States.
But, it's like you just do this totally absurd straw man that
nobody is actually arguing. Nobody's really saying that. It's
so goofy, man. >> with that. No, no, I I I totally agree
with that. I mean, it's just the we just have to be very I like
I always say, like calibrated and and careful about what we're
saying. If what we're saying is the DNC had a preference for
Hillary Clinton, that's just true. If if we have a, you know,
a claim that well, but for the DNC's interference, Bernie would
have won. I'm not convinced of that. I don't think that's true.
>> I still think Bernie can win 2016 and I have a little
like [laughter] strings and and a, you know, crazy conspiracy
board down in my basement, so we're we're we're we're still charting
out the path, but it's going to happen. >> Well, but does
anybody here think that >> that's a perfect segue into
the idea that Trump might have won 2020.
How do you not segue into Kash Patel
that Donald he's actually going to make arrests or going to present
evidence that the 2020 election was rigged?
You guys see that? Am I the only one who saw that? That's a perfect
segue right >> I'll sign Yeah, talk about that, right?
>> loses, Hassan will say, "You know what? We We tried
our best and all's fair and square. We'll come back next time
and try again." I don't care
>> What if it wasn't fair and square, >> What do
you This is How much of a smile do you want them to have while
they eat a plate of [__]
I think if you want them to fully smile, that's never going to
happen. You're running a liberal coalition, nobody will do that.
Go over to the Republican side, you got all these servile, spineless
pieces of [__] over there, okay? That's more your
speed.
He can't uh cuz again, I I know there will be things that go
go badly. And
if they lose, they should be able to say, "Well, yeah, this the
stuff went against us and it's it's unfair, but
you vote McMorrow cuz she's way better than any Republican that
could possibly run." You didn't see that? Yeah, he announced
that. I I think he announced that, at least I've seen it a couple
times. What's up, Koser? I've got a clip of yours, Koser, in
the in the chamber here, we'll see.
What did I have that for? I don't even remember the story.
I got a clip of yours somewhere in here. What was it for? Was
it for the Fuentes
Maybe it's for the Fuentes oiler stuff. Oh, it was just a little
aside. Okay, I think we're Are we almost done with this cuz I
might do
I'll I'll probably just do this by itself, just some little Anarchist
Fairy thing with Fuentes, which is kind of >> Kid myself,
he will. It >> What did he say? >> doubt and and
discuss. >> Put Gazela cuz he supported her, right? And
she lost. Did he say it was rigged? Did I mean, I'm sure he talked
about like, "Oh, AIPAC put out these ads against her or like,
you know, there was an establishment bias." But that is a good
question. What did he say about I would gauge that as like a
I don't know what he would say at this one if he loses. >> He
seems much more invested in this one.
I do >> He literally had Kat on his stream. What do you
mean he's much more invested in this one? >> Didn't he
turn on Gazela because he didn't like her foreign policy takes?
>> Guy just does nothing, but I
How do you How do you stream 8 hours a day and still manage to
watch every single second of the Destiny stream, Hutch? Is it
because you play half of his stream on your stream? I actually
don't know. It's very interesting to me. Like, dude, that's that's
just such a >> Are we still talking about Hasan right >> No,
it was the opposite. >> are we talking about Hasan? That's
That's a great question. >> Thank you. Thank you, everybody.
Everybody's just like, dude, I really?
>> That is a great question. If you ask me that, I'm going
to lose >> Oh wait, they were Sorry, they were already
talking about Hasan. Why are they saying why are we still talking
about Hasan? Cuz they don't want to they don't want to point
out how stupid that statement was, or they don't want to actually,
you know, say no people He actually stood against the left flank
on Twitch even. They stood against
Like he stood against Mike from PA and said, "You know what?
I understand why you're saying this. I don't agree with your
policy, but she's the best candidate we've got. We're riding
with And even Mike, you know, bent to Hasan's wisdom on that
eventually. Like I Yeah, I don't know, it's crazy. It's just
It doesn't It's not
reality. We're not in reality anymore. >> Who's my >> Wait,
what? What did I ask? What did I >> Why are we talking
about Hasan? >> But you're not allowed to ask that of all
people. >> No, I didn't say that. I said, "Wait, I >> You
were I mean, you were already talking about Hasan via the El
Sayed stuff. I I was like, "Wait, it's Hasan again." No, that's
not the dumb thing about Hutch What Hutch said. Hutch just said
something that was totally wrong. The dumb thing that You You
guys were talking about Hasan. That was literally the topic.
That's where you started. >> "Are we talking about Hasan?"
Not "Why are we talking about Hasan?" >> Ooh, who I got
triggered. >> Um I'm asking why. >> He went uh he
went against his chat cuz his chat was like condemning >> You
guys are all Oh god. I just watched I just watched Soy Pill and
over.
He's reading Kilo DMs right now. Okay? This is what's happening.
This is So, he's looking over here when he's streaming. And then
when he goes to read the Kilo DM right here. >> He went
uh he went against his chat cuz his chat was like condemning
her. >> That's the Kilo DM right there. You guys see the
switch over? He's He's going He goes to read and he goes, "Oh
yeah, right. Went against his chat for Cat Ab
Dude, total Kilo victory on this one. Total cabal victory. We
actually got Soy Pill. He's on our side.
I didn't think it won. But it won. He won.
Thank you, Kilo. Thank you.